[Musique]
un carrosse un instant s'efforçant de
passer dans ce grand embarras souvient
embarrassé 20 carrosse bientôt arrivant
à la fidi sont en moins de rien suivi de
plus de 1000 et pour surcroît de mot un
seul malencontreux conduit en cet
endroit un grand troupeau de b
ainsi voit l'eau en 1660 décrivait déjà
les embarras de paris en 1970 après plus
de trois siècles
il est rare de croiser des troupeaux
dans la capitale mais les embarras on ne
vous l'apprendra pas n'ont pas disparu
[Musique]
dans la région parisienne on estime
qu'il y à deux millions cinq cent mille
voitures à paris même
neuf cent trente mille voitures sont
immatriculés ces chiffres sont en
constante augmentation
comme la surface des ruelles n'augmente
par les déplacements des parisiens sont
de plus en plus difficile
nous nous sommes livrés à une expérience
nous sommes 4 et si daniel durand des
claude lefebvre et pierre orofino nous
nous trouvons place pie xi nous allons
nous rendre à la bastille avec chacun un
moyen de locomotion différents moi même
j'irai en vélomoteur daniel moi je
prends l'autobus 54 disent ils jusqu'à
la république après ça le 65 jusqu'à la
bastille claude bien voitures
particulières par les grands boulevards
barbès rochechouart magenta république
et bastille lumière le métro jusqu'à
stalingrad changement est arrivé à la
bastille va donc s'agir pour nous d'une
course nous partons tous ensemble et
l'on verra avec ses moyens de locomotion
quel sera le premier arrivé il est très
exactement 10h33
nous partons tout de suite aux rockets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une première constatation sur les
grandes artères les feux rouges sont
très rarement synchronisée et provoque
une perte de temps certaines
[Musique]
pour cette expérience nous avions choisi
les meilleures conditions un jour de
semaine
en fin de matinée la circulation est
fluide aux heures de pointe
les résultats ne peuvent être
qu'aggraver
et ben voilà je fais pas chez eux en
cette période henry au moteur mais on
arrive très vite de ce parti à 10h33 de
la place mii si j'y arrive le premier à
me manquer il exactement
10h53 20 minutes donc pour molière
afficher la main
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai exactement rongeurs forme à
moncheaux claude parti à 11h33 se fait
donc à faire et quelques rapides
une demi heure pour venir une grille oui
les circulation était relativement
fluide particulier sur les grands
boulevards et certainement qu aux heures
de pointe un doigt m
certainement le double de temps
pierre arrivé en troisième position par
le métro à ma montre
11h07 donc plus d'une demi heure et 35
minutes
ceci s'est passé
très bien une attente de cinq minutes à
chaque métro
reste le maître n'a pas trop de vendre
mais non pas du tout nous n'avons pas
utilisé de taxi cas pour la grande
majorité des parisiens leur tarif élevé
en font un moyen de transport
occasionnel surtout pas cours daniel
durand des arrivé en quatrième position
ou amis 57 minutes pour faire le trajet
mais par l'autobus je suis parti dans le
même temps que tout le monde 25 minutes
j'attendis l'autobus place clichy 25
minutes après ça un quart d'heure pour
aller jusque-là public sans problème
changement il s'est fait encore peu près
en cinq minutes et dix minutes pour
venir ici vous dites 55 minutes 57
minutes exactement première jusqu'ici
avec une circulation qui était
relativement fluide les conséquences de
cette expérience sont évidentes d'abord
dans paris le deux roues et route comme
moyen de transport en commun
le métro est sûr relativement rapide
mais à quelles conditions aux heures
d'affluence foule entassement
invraisemblable atmosphère irrespirable
en surface le service des autobus
fonctionne mal et fonctionnera toujours
mans il ya là un cercle vicieux les
autobus circulent mal car il ya dans les
rues trop de voitures particulières et
comme il circule mal les usagers renonce
à les utiliser et se servent de plus en
plus de leur propre voiture
c'est un paradoxe le plus sûr et fait
des difficultés de circulation et
d'inciter un nombre croissant de
personnes à utiliser la voiture
individus on a créé des couloirs
spécialement réservée aux autobus
cela a amené une amélioration sensible
mais aussi certains inconvénients
ces voix sont souvent est inévitablement
obstruée et lorsqu'un camion pour
décharger ne se met pas en stationnement
dans le couloir lui même il se met à
côté ce qui provoque une gêne pour le
reste de la circulation
[Musique]
mais la situation est encore plus grave
car nous sommes en pleine régression
en 1905 la vitesse moyenne des autobus
était de 15 km heure aujourd'hui elle
est de 10 km heure et encore sur
certains axes des centaines jusqu'à 8 km
saint c'est la circulation en général a
baissé dans les mêmes proportions
la vitesse moyenne dans les douze
dernières années a chuté de 33%
on s'en doute cette régression ces
difficultés de déplacement représente
une grande perte financière des études
nombreuses ont été faites elles sont
difficiles les calculs sont très
subtiles
sans entrer dans leurs détails vous faut
savoir que la mauvaise circulation dans
paris coûte au bas mot 500 millions de
francs 50 milliards d'anciens francs de
perte ou de manque à gagner 50 milliards
gaspillés en vapeurs d'essence
une mauvaise circulation à bien d'autres
conséquences néfastes la pollution
atmosphérique par exemple dans les
embouteillages souvent il faut abréger
le service des agents de police ils
risquent d'être incommodés par les gaz
d'échappement depuis le 1er janvier une
stricte réglementation est appliqué la
teneur en oxyde de carbone du gaz
d'échappement des voitures ne doit pas
dépasser 4,5 pour cent des contrôles
sont effectués des amendes sévères sont
appliqués mais cela n'empêche pas un
véhicule sur deux d'être mal réglée il
laisse pas échapper une trop grande
quantité de da stocks
[Applaudissements]
n'oublions pas enfin tous les autres
déchets laissés par l'automobile
salissement de la capitale détérioration
des sites voiture et pas etc
on le voit la situation est donc très
sombre quelles sont les solutions que
l'on envisage il ya là en fait une lueur
d'espoir depuis quelque temps un certain
équilibre tant à s'instituer 900 mille
voitures à peu près entre chaque jour
dans paris mais c'est important un
nombre sensiblement égal en sort dans le
même temps la banlieue s'est développée
on ya vu beaucoup de créations d'emplois
aussi la demande aujourd'hui
concerne-t-elle autant des liaisons
banlieue banlieue que des liaisons
banlieues paris c'est dans ce sens qu'on
était décidé les grands travaux du 6e
plan les grands travaux d'aménagement
sont en effet un des remèdes à apporter
à la circulation
construira donc au tour de paris une
autoroute de rocade une sorte de
boulevard périphérique de banlieue qui
encerclera la capitale à cinq ou six
kilomètres de distance est prévu
également le doublement de l'autoroute
du nord et de l'auto de l'ouest enfin le
lancement de deux nouvelles autoroutes
de dégagement l'une vers pontoise à
l'ouest l'autre vers croatie à l'est
mais à l'intérieur même de paris quels
sont les grands travaux que l'on peut
envisage d'abord le périphérique tout
autour de paris dont la construction
s'achève eu la voie express rive droite
on peut envisager la praille cause d'une
gauche certaines pénétrante dans paris
mais tout cela a des limites
on ne peut pas à taillader la capitale
d'un réseau d'autoroutes urbaines ce
n'est pas impensable non seulement sur
le plan financier mais même sur le plan
psychologique esthétiques historiques
croyez vous que ce serait vraiment
insupportable que l'on puisse pas ce que
l'on voudrait accepter davantage
d'automobiles dans paris de sacrifier
des perspectives
séculaire de saccager des sites d'abîmer
des monuments ça me semble vraiment
impensable
on peut toujours dire que le baron
haussmann à son époque a fait des
travaux semblables
oui vous pourriez que les frais
maintenant contenu
la nécessité d'obtenir un consentement
général je crois que c'est absolument
indispensable dans tous ces problèmes
c'est de faire comprendre aux gens qu'il
faut qu'ils s'auto discipline il ya un
minimum de consentement qui est
indispensable et je crois que les
connaissances pas du tout les mêmes
c'est existait du temps de ben arous
marne et seine auquel nous avons à faire
face actuellement
si les grands travaux d'aménagement sont
forcément limitée intérieur des murs de
paris il faut chercher d'autres
solutions et plus immédiat on pense
alors aux mesures autoritaires aux
mesures d'interdiction à ce sujet nous
avons rencontré dans la salle de
commandement de la préfecture de police
monsieur gilles le directeur de la
circulation parisienne
il est il déjà nombreuses interdictions
notamment des interdictions de
stationner sur les 1150 km de voie
parisienne
il y en a déjà trois cents sur lesquels
il est interdit de stationner
[Musique]
et
le voir et ce n'est un secret pour
personne les mesures d'interdiction de
stationnement sont bien souvent
inefficaces elles n'empêchent pas le
stationnement un archet on cite même des
exemples invraisemblable ainsi des
policiers sont en train de procéder à
l'enlèvement d'une voiture dans le cadre
d'une opération grue derrière un
automobiliste a tant que la voiture soit
enlevé pour prendre sa place à la
préfecture on déclare que le montant des
contraventions est trop peu élevé pour
être dissuasive faut donc s'attendre
dans les mois qui vont suivre à une
augmentation une forte augmentation des
contraventions
[Musique]